[Music]
second hour rotc
uh we are going to have a guest here for
in a second but first want to set it up
obviously we've been talking
about
oh the canadian trucker protest that's
going on
uh and i'm gonna play a couple things
for them we're gonna let we're gonna let
the gentleman on who's on the ground or
who's on the ground there anyway uh
but first folks i just did a [ __ ]
huge dab i just did one too but i'm a
man
um
[Music]
so here's what there's here's what
ottawa police are saying
you have increased ability to identify
and target protesters
and supporters of protesters
who are funding
and enabling
unlawful and harmful activity
by the protesters themselves what
harmful unlawful activity are they doing
blocking traffic which i thought was i
thought you were we were allowed to do
the left said we were it was good it was
good
since when are protests ever supposed to
make people feel comfortable
isn't that what you guys said god
they're selective [ __ ]
their selective outrageous i'm getting
real tired of it evidence gathering
teams
are collecting financial
digital
vehicle registration
driver identification get ready boys
they're going to do it to to you guys
what happened on january 6th
insurance status and other related
evidence that will be used in
prosecutions
every that's a good way to win over your
trucking force by threatening to arrest
them that's fine you know what they're
not storming into capital buildings and
you're gonna have a lot harder to see
this is like if the january 6 if the
retards that actually did storm that
building
hadn't have done that
they would have had so much harder of a
[ __ ] time selling people on all of
these prosecutions
so all the truckers here have to do
is behave
now
just behave
and keep doing what you're doing boys
and trust me there will be money raised
for your defenses there will be an
outrage there will be an outcry for you
these people on january 6 that i i know
they didn't really
you know they obviously there aren't
terrorists like they got labeled
but some of them did some [ __ ] [ __ ]
and gave the media some excellent
footage to play on a loop which makes
getting normies to you know to take up
their [ __ ] fight a lot harder like
they kind of [ __ ] it up like a small
group of [ __ ] [ __ ] up january 6
for everybody
if the truckers can just get get their
people under control make sure that
everybody's doing what they've been
doing which is hanging out having
[ __ ] cookouts eating polish sausages
in the street and honking their goddamn
horns
just keep doing that and and and keep
disavowing any fed like [ __ ] behavior
and if you guys get arrested don't worry
people are gonna people are gonna come
out for you way stronger than the
[ __ ] well plus plus the january sixth
thing was based in
you know
a not commonly held belief that the
election was rigged and i know some of
us think that the election wasn't on the
up and up whoa whoa not me
fortified
all i'm saying is
if
people tend to think like oh well i
think the election's rigged everyone
must think it it was not despite what
all you want to believe it was never a
widely held belief
that that the election was rigged
it is however a widely held belief
that these lockdowns are [ __ ] and
they have to end
so there's a lot of good karma on the
side of these truckers as opposed to the
january 6 people so if they just as long
as they don't [ __ ] it up
some of you are gonna have to get
arrested bottom line sucks they're doing
better than not [ __ ] it up the the
trudeau's administration was trying to
spread rumors that the truckers were
eating food that was there for homeless
people
however here's a video of the truckers
making meals for homeless
people yeah because that's the thing
dude so many people have brought food
for the truckers there's probably more
food in ottawa than there are people to
eat it
so this is them do uh
see right there
that's some donating food to the canada
unity like you know the people that do
the uh the food and stuff that is
[Music]
that's pretty that's pretty [ __ ]
funny right
well well uh we have a somebody who was
there he's not a trucker but he was at
the rally his name is andrew and he's a
fan and let's get him on right now let's
let's see what he let's see what he has
to say
okay do we got him i admit
there he is okay it's your audio turn
your audio on
god he looks canadian
uh connecting to audio okay turn connect
your audio
he's he's connecting his
audio
connect connect your audio
[Laughter]
i set him up so great too right you saw
that great setup
okay now unmute your microphone
your microphone's muted i just unmute
your microphone andrew
andrew i mute your microphone i can't
hear you if your microphone's muted
and your suit no no you turned your
camera off turn your camera you guys
can't see what i'm seeing turn your
camera back on and unmute your
microphone oh god
oh god
this is going great
you know what okay his camera's back on
but
you're on mute your microphone
every time royce finds a man on the
street yes hey there you go
man i finally made it
what's up man how you doing
dude this is the first time i've ever
even [ __ ] used zoom i was kind of
hoping you were gonna call me on
wednesday and do that bro you're so
canadian
uh it's awesome
so so uh you you were at the rally uh
you said this past weekend
yeah buddy yeah that was absolutely wild
man the energy that was in the air like
i i
i think you understand what i say as a
canadian
i haven't felt that before that felt
very much like uh
uh early trump days you know what i mean
like that before he you know kind of
sucked yeah but yeah
so so i guess we should probably start
from the beginning so when did you
decide to become a terrorist yeah we
should ask that were you exposed to
extremist beliefs as a young child or
were you
was it something you picked up uh
elsewhere in your adult life or were you
radicalized at some point
yes i pay taxes
that's the best i don't turn anybody
into a terrorist
i guess i'm a white supremacist
[ __ ] me
so yeah you were on the ground you were
on the ground there what's the what's
the vibe like
it's a party it felt like canada today
i'm part of the hill i lived in ottawa
for 12 years i went to high school out
there i did all that stuff you know what
i mean uh
i've lost my boy i lost my voice on the
weekend i still haven't got it back i
apologize now you know i
would have been back today but
definitely not
uh
the vibe on the on the ground there man
canada they do like
absolutely
electric
like the people around
it
i've never felt something like that in
so long you know what i mean we've been
locked down here for two years dude i
can't go anywhere i'm unboxing i can't
go i i can't even my wife just
registered my daughter for uh for
swimming lessons i can't go watch or
swim seriously
so wait you need to be vaccinated just
to watch just to go towards to see like
a kid's swimming thing
dude you can't go into rec center you
can't go watch kids play hockey unless
you're backstage dude
like the stories i've been hearing that
i heard i i heard a few stories yeah but
hockey's not like a big thing in canada
yeah no it's not
that's not a huge pastime or anything
it's just it's kind of a pastime
you know just uh we we actually we're
kind of impartial about it we're
thinking about bringing lacrosse out you
know because hockey sucks
actually hockey does suck man because
this in the 90s anymore you see the see
the penalties and the fines these guys
are getting you can't take a man's head
off anymore
what is that yeah it's so
good up here
so so man it's so that had to be nice
especially if you're somebody that's not
even allowed to leave the house to see
so many people that think the same and i
know a lot of people at this thing are
vaccinated they just don't want [ __ ]
mandates
well it dude i was talking to the ndp
uh supporters i was talking to liberal
supporters i was talking to
conservatives i was talking to the ppc
this isn't like what they're painting it
to be this is
everybody is [ __ ] fed up we've all
sorry about swear i i don't know what
the yeah
yeah we don't curse on this show man all
right this is you know this is a family
show yeah
this is a family show yeah i i don't
know all right honestly
we're fed up up here man like dude we've
done we we've done two years of this we
put in
enough effort to it that everybody's
asked for us all our state
representative or provincial
representatives or federal
representatives
of us
and uh people are tired and they're
tired from every walk of life
like it's not just
oh uh the trump support and
conservatives like novant like dude i
was running into
i ran into a dude for like from way up
in northwest territories like way up
there the guy drove you know it was
30 something hours he said to be there
for one for a couple of days you know
what i mean this is a vibe that's going
on in canada right now it's it's
something
well
i'll say i'll say this it's it's not
it's it is nice to see from here because
you know all we see you know in the
states all we see is my god why would
they let them so why would they let
themselves be you know governed like
this why why do they let this art
teacher or [ __ ] drama teacher tell
you guys what to do and it's nice to see
that a bunch of you guys are like look
we're canadians we're not [ __ ] so you
better [ __ ] stop it
if we're not yeah
but like the thing is that people don't
like i know you got like your election
process it's 50 50 right
i mean on paper on paper on paper yeah
yeah sure
it's up in canada man we got the ndp we
got the liberals who are basically in
cohorts
like they they just work together
regardless just to crush conservatives
or whoever right
and
now we're getting the ppc which is
people's party in canada which is maxine
bernier we call mad max this guy's a
lunatic i love him
but
like you know and even now like our
conservatives are only conservative in
name
like well hey man you know let me tell
you something you might but that's kind
of like what's going on here i mean we
we have
we have a couple that aren't
men no dude like we literally have
liberal conservatives or conservatives
there is no there's no
i i
the only thing that they the
conservatives do different from the
liberals in canada is re-name things
that's all they do they still want the
carbon tax they still want the vaccine
mandates that's why o'toole got was
gotten rid of two days ago
because he still supports it and he
still wants to he still wanted to push
ahead with it even with what's going on
he like i think you know the higher ups
might have gone to him too and finally
said like you know we can't use you
anymore and i believe you know
that justin trudeau has
used up his worth in the eyes of his
whole handlers right like the same way
that you guys have your handlers for joe
biden states
it's even worse up here and i think
they're setting him up for a complete
failure
who would go in hiding five days before
hides and he says he has kova now here's
another question i have for you you were
uh you were there and speaking of
handlers and stuff did you see any
obvious plants or feds
it's actually funny to say that i was
listening verse last night talking about
that uh that glowy
[Laughter]
flag with the truck in the middle now
i spent my like i'm not too busy at work
greenhouse i got a lot of time and last
week when you guys left for vegas i had
extra time because i didn't watch your
show twice like you know what i mean
so
i was i saw the flag down at parliament
hill and i thought to myself i'm like
[ __ ]
it's weird to see a confederate flag up
here yeah it doesn't make it it honestly
makes no sense makes zero sense yeah why
would you have that
absolutely no part of our history
yeah yeah exactly thanks again
oh god there's two canadians on now i
don't like this
it's freaking hot
this is weird too it's too many
canadians on today
so what is what is this steven crowder
show
so go ahead go ahead
oh the 6.4 boomer
the chad giggle boomer
yeah yeah oh he's the worst
anyway so you're saying the confederate
flag yeah i saw the flag there i didn't
think anything of it at first i'm like
well because i've watched enough
american protests that it just didn't
like compute
but then they started thinking about not
only is this a confederate flag but this
is a confederate flag with a picture of
a semi in the middle of it
yeah where do you buy that
oh my god that is a really good point
i went on google and i started searching
for every
different wording of confederate flag
with truck in the middle
there is no flag that exists now this is
where it gets fun
one of justin trudeau's
personal photographers i can't
okay yeah i'm nervous so i can't really
remember his first name
scotty spells s-c-o-t-t-i
now
a lot of people at the protest think
they have a picture of this guy
following that flag around
oh yeah yeah he just he just happened to
be i saw that he just happened to be
there yep
yeah and then not only that no yeah a
pickup truck that's the only one i know
that's the only one you can find yeah
so like i'm looking at and i'm thinking
i'm like this is this is see-through
this is glowing this is neon baby yeah
like what i mean
so and then i started thinking i'm like
what about that nazi flag well people
who are not familiar with uh the
nation's capital which is everyone
pretty much watching this show yes he
was walking along the canal okay which
is like the world's longest skating rink
oh sweet we gotta go [ __ ] skating
uh he's walking along the canal
and only one pitcher one single pitcher
the the people at that rally from the
groups that i've been on facebook would
have singled him out in two seconds the
same way that they called him and called
out that guy with the confederate flag
but me being like you know i'm kind of
in tune with what's going on down south
it just didn't like you know what i mean
i would have loved to
[ __ ]
i would have loved to have found a neon
guy but i just didn't think it would
have been
that much of a [ __ ] effort out of the
government you know what i mean no but
you know you know what the problem is is
that you guys are you guys are still
just a little more new to it because
we've been doing it here forever
so don't worry you'll learn i mean
they'll learn you know even here look
even here they don't got it down when
all those fed shop weren't here and the
rallies were in the same military-grade
watches and we're like oh okay yeah
sure yeah i saw a picture everybody
standing with the same cut shorts yeah
that's so yeah we we got we got pros
here and even they [ __ ] suck
oh yeah
no but honestly dude like uh the energy
in canada right now even from my
as far well you guys covered it uh i
think it was the other day the alberta
the crew's border
uh what's his name paul brandt the
country singer's going down there to
start singing convoy okay that's
hilarious
that's [ __ ] hilarious
you've got helicopters flying supplies
in past the police barricades
they don't give a [ __ ] out there that's
crazy that i've been able to spend a lot
of time across this country i went to
school into mexico i went to i worked
out in alberta for
four years on the oil rigs and i met all
kinds of people through bc saskatchewan
alberta quebec ontario
uh even like it was
you you worked on an oil rig
oh yeah okay so did that did michael bay
ever ask you to go to space and destroy
uh and destroy
a meteor
[ __ ] wish he did
that's crazy do you know what i just
realized merce this guy's like a real
man you know like yeah i wouldn't know
what that's like yeah i have no idea
what that's like like he's actually like
yeah i worked in an oil rig you know i
do man stuff and i'm like i do a show
with my friend on the internet
yeah
like you guys i'm mad about lockdowns
and i don't even really leave the house
yeah that's a good point we have no
reason to be mad
four o'clock dude
i'm i i sh everybody can [ __ ] off
i don't care at work
oh wait hey you fire me i'll walk down
the street you know it's funny because
there's some news here for frozen i
heard that that they they they're moving
down over to toronto soon they were
talking about uh
well yeah they're talking about doing a
protest downtown and i'm in that group
too yeah
i've strongly discouraged trucks parking
and like and not for the same reason
that you think like
not because like i feel like there's any
danger or anything in toronto it's
because
you've got princess margaret cancer
hospital or cancer hospital down there
you got sick kids toronto down there you
got uh st michael's
general this is the hub for the
hospitals in the city that take in a lot
of really sick people from around so
i've been trying to you know promote
more of a like
online promotional
you know what's fun oh wow okay you hear
that marsh another white supremacist
trying to shut down cities it's
hilarious whenever you talk to people
that have been there and support this
stuff they're so thoughtful like he was
just like look there's cancer hospitals
there let's not be dicks all right let's
not be dicks about this let's look out
for what other people are doing instead
of just black lives matter that's your
problem you should have done the black
lives matter thing and burned down the
cancer hospital that apparently gets
people to get you to do what they want
right there you go and then you'll be
then you'll be a saint
i like it
yeah yeah i would have been i would have
been saint floyd for sure yeah
oh [ __ ]
but yeah man i mean that's that's
awesome dude it really is it's it's um
it's great to actually talk to somebody
that was there and and and and the fact
that people are fighting back is is is
great you know
and honestly royce i've never seen this
out of the canadian people before the
spirit that's coming man because i'll be
honest i didn't know you had it in you
me neither
i didn't know i knew i had it in me
yeah but i didn't know the people around
me
yeah i'm feeling phone calls i'm feeling
10 phone calls a day right now with
people i haven't talked to in two years
three years like that have you know
shunned me out because of the way that i
think and now all of a sudden
right we're all in agreement you know
and i
i don't hold it against people i
understand like the power of the media
and like the way that it can be easily
well i mean especially your media right
because you guys only have like three
stations and they're all the same they
all think the same thing so yeah and
they only get [ __ ] 1 000 likes on
their facebook pages like come on oh
yeah do you know you know you know who
only gets a thousand likes when they go
live are [ __ ] president so we know
what is it 30 or uh what yeah you guys
are 300 and uh
336 350 now population give or take a
billion yeah you know say you're 10
times worse yeah
yeah it's true nobody nobody likes them
but you know it's that that's that's
great man like is is there any way
people like how can people [ __ ] help
like kids is there go fund me or
something
the gofundme and this is this is
something i actually want to touch on
sure there is issues with it from the
beginning
but not the same issues that the media
is portraying so they're saying it's
getting shut down for every lake that
they reach so when it reached 5 million
right
they the media came in and oh it's shut
down and it's oh this and that no that
wasn't the case right they were just
gofundme has responsibility to make sure
that the person in charge of it is not
going to steal it once oh yeah yeah that
i do know they do that for when
especially when there's a certain amount
yeah right and then i i'm guessing
either 10 million is the next mark or
there was some pressure coming out of
ottawa that made this happen again but
i'm on the live streams with like i'm
i'm watching these live streams with
tamara and brian and it's like what
they pulled up a news article it's like
tamara has left ottawa and stole 10
million dollars and then brian comes on
on his tick tock brian 1975 five
first three uh his uh twitter sorry
yeah his uh
uh instead not instagram what the [ __ ]
cringe talk his tick tock is [ __ ] uh
now donna's paul's gonna get a big head
great
[ __ ] me oh now all of a sudden he's
gonna be hurt all of a sudden he's gonna
be arrogant
1975 5
follow this guy this guy is absolutely
on top of it he's a leader of the
obstacle of the movement and uh he uh
like he's a very well-spoken man you
know and he's uh one of the beginning
guys that were
you know coming out from alberta from uh
bc or whatever but
yeah like um they're opening up by
there's something called adopt a trucker
so it's
do i need to like feed them and take
them out like how does that work
oh you just have money
is it like ground is it like gremlins
where i can't feed him after midnight
like how does it work when you adopt the
trucker
when you pop the trucker you need to go
pick him up royce oh [ __ ] and you've got
to be
and you got to be loaded up you got to
have a dirty 30 and netties yes and you
gotta have gas station dick pills
and you got to [ __ ] that's what they
want baby and they want [ __ ] they
want [ __ ] sausage egg and cheese from
[ __ ] flying j's
okay and they're good to go hey what's
your beaver situation like
i'm bieber i got it
and they'll help you run a little drugs
too as long as it's a small amount and
it's not going to really show up in a
large [ __ ] freight you know that's
fine don't ask him to carry too much
that's the key
if you bring me the good kind of snow
from florida i'll help you
i can't i can't imagine you guys have
great cocaine i can't imagine
bright shitty canadian imagine how many
times it gets stepped on by the time you
get into ottawa
i know
from when it comes from the from when it
comes to port of miami all the way up to
ottawa you're like this is mostly just
baby laxative and i'm mostly just having
to take a lot of like wet shits now i'm
not happy
the cocaine is so bad up here that you
have to [ __ ] before you even do your
first life
man when i remember on the sopranos when
christopher was like man it got so bad
if i just smelled money after a while
i'd have to take a [ __ ] and i was like
oh my god i felt that
[Laughter]
oh man but yeah you were sorry you were
saying adopt the trucker how does that
work atop the trucker that's the uh the
new platform they're trying to go with i
think i believe it's a website it's just
this thing's
it's all happening so fast because it's
grassroots right so they're trying to
get organized at school and they've had
a week
week and a half realistically when it
really got big
and they kind of understood the gravity
of the situation start hiring lawyers
start hugging accountants to make sure
that everything's going to get
distributed properly now like merch was
saying again last night on day or on the
night wave
do not do gofundme
do not [ __ ] do go because they'll
shut it down they'll shut it i knew i
knew that was a bad idea when i saw all
that money on gofundme and i was like
they're not going to get that money yeah
you called it and i was watching it too
and it's like
this is easy for the government to uh
uh use their influence to uh to uh
attack this situation right because they
know that is the lifeline
that being said they were [ __ ] wrong
because
the people that are pouring out of the
surrounding area in ottawa
into the city
to bring them everything they need i'm
using live streams this guy uh uh
rhizock durham okay
i just felt d-u-r-h-a i'm just like
[ __ ]
the guy in your office where the [ __ ]
trump's buddy
these guys are hauling fuel
with radio flyer [ __ ] wagons
because they will not let fuel trucks
into the city they only recently even
gave them a permit for porta potties
like this week dude well here's a
question you know it's funny you say
that here's a question i heard the tow
truckers they they try to get tow trucks
to move them and the tow truckers just
wouldn't help them did that also happen
that sounds that's [ __ ] awesome by
the way
for an hour and a half with citywide
towing out of calgary when they were
threatened when they took pictures right
you guys were pictures of the trucks
down at the border like these [ __ ]
cowards are coming in they're gonna take
our trucks out of here blah blah blah so
i was like [ __ ] you too so i got on the
phone and i [ __ ] called their office
and they had already pulled their
[ __ ] trucks out because they had they
don't want anything to do
guys
i [ __ ] pray that the military starts
dragging vehicles can you imagine how
bad that would be
against canadians for [ __ ] sakes yeah
you know what i love all people that
actually deserve getting dragged out by
tanks canadians i think are last on that
list yeah that's a good point like i
mean that's [ __ ] it's hilarious have
you tried like not going around and
murdering people of color and training
with people
well i tried but i suck at that so
[Laughter]
but that's funny man it's so funny to
see like and here's why because the tow
truck drivers and and
truck drivers and all that oh there's a
lot of overlap right there's a lot of
overlapping
exactly well that's why the tow truck
drivers yeah they're like yeah i'm not
doing it yeah no no
if these companies want to commit
financial suicide the dust will settle
one day right and we're going to be able
to
we're going to be able to vote with our
dollars
yeah
unless gofundme takes them that's a good
point yeah you know what i'd suggest you
guys get a bitcoin wallet
[Laughter]
when i thought it was actually smart
[ __ ] years ago
oh [ __ ]
man uh yeah any other questions you got
from marsh
uh actually i was just i was not a
question but i was going to bring up did
jim post it somebody posted the [ __ ]
gibson go link in the chat yes let me
grab that can you yeah somebody post
that again so we can yeah these guys are
obviously this is my first time even
using zoom like i'm not i'm not that guy
like uh technologically
that's this and obviously the moment i
looked at you i knew you weren't a
viewer and a tech guy you worked in a
[ __ ] oil rig
or was it the [ __ ] mute for the first
minute which was very funny by the way
um
but yeah man uh we'll post so basically
uh when when uh
what what are your demands and uh what
what are the uh
when are you going to stop being
terrorists yeah that's interesting and
killing literally everybody yeah that
would be great has anybody been killed
with a fire extinguisher do we know
um
not reported yet but unsubstantiated
claims
the fire extinguisher also had a
confederate flag with a truck on it too
it's really weird
that announcement flag and i believe the
guy was wearing kkk hood wow all of
those things that which is weird because
the kkk is more of an american thing the
fact that you guys have the clan in
canada it's kind of odd to me um
so yeah i would highly recommend uh i
would what i would really like to see is
this give send go the adopt a trucker
thing uh i would like to see that have
twice as much money in it in the in the
next month
than the original trucker convoy thing
did
so
i think i highly encourage and i will be
donating to it as well
um i think everybody should throw in a
few bucks this time
yeah uh send go not to go fund me yes
gift send go so yeah this is uh here it
is
uh
see you guys i want to see that thing
hit like 20 mil just to piss them off
even more
yep
that's right and by the way although it
does seem like even they tried to take
the piss out of you by taking the money
out of it but i gotta say it's been
really fun watching just people show up
and just skip the whole money thing and
be like hey we showed up with [ __ ]
donuts and polish sausage and here's
something there's literally like amish
people showing up there's just people
showing up to cook and like i've
literally seen them handing out [ __ ]
booze
like nice
yeah i had a guy i have a i was standing
there at the top apart like right at the
top by the wall they erected we're
trying to figure our way around it being
instructionists and all
but uh this guy had a grocery bag filled
with uh uh twisted knees and uh
and uh white claws in a busted right in
front of us really well
i guess we're friends
by the way if you donate more than fifty
dollars to the adopt the trucker thing
you get a free confederate flag truck
shirt that looks like
it's true
[Laughter]
hey guys i think honestly
i think the biggest trophy
that we've managed to pull out of this
whole situation as a salt that's being
mined out of ottawa residents right now
oh they're so mad at the honking i've
been reading that there was a guy out
there because i haven't slept in three
days because you guys keep honking that
guy that guy was my favorite yeah that
guy was like i'm losing my mind cause i
can't sleep
he was [ __ ] up he did a great he did
a great job
but i
have gone out to the ottawa community
pages
four gems do you mind if i please no go
ahead sir gee do do we gotta get you a
tablet i mean truckers do know right
that there's things like tablets now
how much okay how much does it cost
you got this job you really are a
terrorist you're jotting your manifesto
into a [ __ ] spiral notebook
i couldn't see the name
and she was responding to something no
kidding absolutely shameful
i told someone to pull or pull their
mask up
and they laughed at me and told me mind
my own [ __ ] business
[Laughter]
okay that one was really good
handle
socialist flamethrower
okay
okay [ __ ] it
if they will end the [ __ ] honking
then we will end the [ __ ] mandate
i love this
this is great
listener this is this fun one
monster lever
blm
1312.
okay
blm okay
fun fact my landlord is an anti-faxer
okay
and there's an anti-vaxxed convoy going
through our town
he's allowing anti-baxters
to sit in our parking lot
honking their horns
all night long because he supports them
and they're all outside getting drunk
and singing
[Laughter]
this last one you get back to it and
[ __ ] throw a buddy from uh what well
oh yeah freddie excuse me what excuse me
what comes on
you guys sorry man i'm having a couple
of hits
so uh
jen jeffries
could we get her
uh could we get one hour without horns
just one hour to think great just one
please
i can't it's so funny okay
i didn't [ __ ] i don't even know i've
said that right this is psychological
torture
even after they stop the sounds sounds
still that goes in your
[Laughter]
that's
mind
it's just driving them insane oh [ __ ]
man that's why i love even the video
with that guy screaming when the guy's
like the hogging will continue until
freedom ensues yes
they're calling it a phantom honk the
person's hearing company
hey boys
oh honks
hey hey thank you
andrew you were [ __ ] fantastic we
gotta have him
yeah hey man dude can i just say thank
you for not sucking yeah you were when
we get when we get randos on you never
know but you are [ __ ] great we've
eaten some real [ __ ] sandwiches but you
were fun yeah man you know what we're
gonna have them on again andrew's
welcome on this show again because you
were you were a lot of fun man
appreciate it guys i really appreciate
what you're doing it's nice it's nice
it's nice doing a show with a canadian
that doesn't suck you know
wait a minute
that wasn't nice frozen
poor frozen he's so mean
all right hey man thank you andrew
really appreciate it buddy
cheers guys have a good night later
see you
see you later
he goes
he was [ __ ] great holy [ __ ] he was a
lot of fun i really liked him